er und andere eu länder öffnen kriechen
wir noch fünf wochen der freiheit
entgegen pünktlich zum morgigen corona
gipfel mit den länderchefs hat das
kanzleramt einen ersten fahrplan für das
ende der korona maßnahmen vorgelegt
vierten märz sollen restaurants hotels
die dreijährige gelten klingt erst mal
gut am 20 märz soll dann der folie
modell sein es sollen alle
tiefgreifenden schutz maßnahmen fallen
aber die maske soll weiterhin den
innenräumen brüsten und bahn getragen
werden was ist das für ein film day für
die kinder ist es noch schlimmer eine
welt recherche ergab dass außer
schleswig holstein bislang nur
rheinland-pfalz und sachsen-anhalt ein
mögliches ende der masten für kinder
schüler platz auf welcher grundlage
sollen die kinder noch länger mit dieser
unsäglichen maske in der schule sitzen
die massen fließen muss endlich fallen
und das für alle und wir müssen meiner
meinung nach sofort öffnen ich hoffe
dass die deutsche politik sich wir sind
wir beim fühlen date nicht wieder den
deutschen corona sonderweg hinlegen